foreign
Grant joins us in Spokane Washington
Grant welcome to the show
thank you very much gentlemen I just
want to say thanks for accomplishing
your mission on a daily basis oh thank
you oh that's very nice thank you sir
what's going on all right
um baby step number three is where my
wife and I are at we've been married for
16 years we have five kids and legal
separation was proposed she brought it
up the last night when we were talking
we have four thousand dollars to the
penny in our emergency fund right now
and I think we've never established a
monthly budget that I think our net to
cover is between three thousand and
thirty five hundred dollars just to
survive so we have essentially A month's
worth of savings right now
my question for you is
should I add a second job to go gazelle
intense to bump up our savings or is it
more important to deal with my mental
health and my marriage
in this season
also one part of this is my mental
health I was diagnosed with bipolar a
number of years ago I think five years
ago and I was just on manic phase
yesterday oh my goodness are you seeing
someone or have you seen a counselor a
medical professional for this I I am
being treated by my team I have a
counselor that I see on a weekly basis I
have a psychiatrist that I've seen I
think five or six times in the last
three months and they're actively
managing my meds and I just had a
medication change just today and we're
trying to find the right balance for the
different mood stabilizers and the
different medications that I think I've
been on six or seven different
medications in the last four years I
mean do you and the team feel like
there's progress that has been made and
that it's at least while we're still
testing and trying that there's some
progress I think I think we're testing
and trying I know that uh in September I
was I was hospitalized twice one was
voluntary the other one was involuntary
and it's been
it's been a hard life for my wife just
dealing with my moods and uh she she's
receiving counseling for herself
individually over the last year and
she's not willing to go back to the
relationship that we used to have just
because it was unhealthy it's an
unhealthy Dynamic where she was trying
to regulate my moods with behaviors that
she would that she no I I don't know
yeah I don't want to crass but she would
try and control me with sex by giving me
what I wanted and it was just it was
unhealthy yeah well so to answer your
question you need to be focusing on your
health and her health yes sir and want
to see you get you know that emergency
fund where it needs to be but we we've
got bigger issues at play right now yeah
I mean a situation like this if it's
heading towards divorce it turns
marriage into a business transaction and
so the goal at that point is to
obviously protect the kids that's the A1
and number two is to make this as little
of a mess as possible with the finances
and so how sure is the separation is
this something you guys are going to try
to work through or is this is this
headed south
well even legally or we've been
separated since November 10th of last
year so it's 11 months in
and it doesn't seem to make we haven't
seen much forward progress we need to
run
intensive marriage counseling weekend
and week out for the last 12 weeks and
it was financially costing us 150 a
session and somebody at our church
established a bit of a fund for the
Higgins family
for us to receive 50 of that counseling
to cover that we were coming out of
pocket 75 a week and
it was a financial there was a pretty
good Financial ask on our on our part so
we were we didn't I can't I can't look
back and say that we've made progress in
the last few months I could say that
times are ongoing we spent the money but
we haven't really made progress and then
you had the conversation last night
where she she brought up let's we need
to make this legal
yes sir so it doesn't look good and and
no and so at this point again the
emergency fund but but you taking a
second job if you've got the health to
do so I don't think that's a
I I don't I don't know if it's a good
thing or a bad thing but bringing in
more income during this season uh might
be a right idea but I certainly would
check with your your uh
your medical team uh on this to see you
know do they feel like this is you know
adding more at work hours during this
transition is that healthy for you I I
ca we can't speak to that it feels like
it may not be yeah I mean you you guys
don't have debt and if this does head to
divorce then you know being married with
16 years five kids then it becomes who's
getting what and custody battles and all
that stuff and so I would I would be
looking at getting a lawyer to figure
this out if it's been 12 months with no
progress yeah
in five weeks it'll be 12 months so
we're not we're not on the 12-month Mark
yet but we're almost to the 11 month
Mark so it's like it's but at that point
I might look at getting separate
checking accounts because the fear is
one spouse drains the account and runs
and you don't have any recourse
if things continue to go south it sounds
like it's been amicable which is great
and everyone's you know we're still
living you're living as roommates
essentially right for the last almost a
year we're we're not in the same
household okay I have them we're
physically we're about three miles apart
where are the kids
with her all four and then the fifth one
our second born as a mythical
relationship with her she's 11 years old
and she's living with her aunt
okay I'm just wondering what what's best
long term for the kids at this point
what's fair to them and living in this
weird Purgatory of our mom and dad
together not it's not official they're
still trying to work through this I'm
just more worried about the kids than
anything at this point and so I would
try to actually have some level of
closure to whatever this is it sounds
like we need to just call it if you've
been living apart for this long
I don't want to give up on it though
well I'm with you brother I I would so
back to the main point of your question
I mean if you've got to work and if you
can do it and you've got to work to to
help pay for the counseling I'd fight
for the marriage I'd fight for I I will
tell you this just candidly
uh one of my closest friends in the
world went through a divorce over a
decade ago and we were recently hanging
out and and it was an amicable divorce
but we were talking about another friend
of ours who's going through a divorce
right now and he told me my friend
that's been divorced now over a decade
he said I would tell him to fight with
every ounce in his body with everything
he's got left fight
to save the marriage because it is so
destructive to the kids to everybody so
I I'm with you man I'd summon every
ounce of strength I've got and and I
would put some of that strength into you
doing everything you can
to get healthy because a healthy you is
the best chance we have of having a
healthy marriage
but I'd fight I think
I'm I hear what you're saying and I want
to fight and
I one thing that specifically that she
said in the last week is that she wants
me to find the program to follow through
on the program and not to Short Circuit
the program
and
yeah just the follow-through and the
consistency is what I need to show you
show myself then do it okay do it you
can decide
you can decide right now do it show her
if you're gonna fight you want to fight
then I'd say all right babe I'm gonna do
it and I'm going to follow through and
show you that I want our marriage to
work hang on the line Grant we're going
to send you a copy of Dr John deloney's
book own your past change your future so
we can continue to walk with you through
this really tough situation thanks for
the call this is the Ramsay show